XO 539 clear vertical to takeoff runway
1 exigent - XO jet is bringing private
aviation to new heights thanks in large
part to its CEO Brad Stuart's been
leading XO jet the third biggest US
private jet leasing company since 2010
he still gets excited flying in a plane
this is such a hard ride together first
one point of view her office downtown
Manhattan right there while Stuart is
mum on client names social media shows a
few stars but they're just in the first
bucket the second is what I call
financier so it's private equity execs
it's whole co-executive people who are
buying and selling companies hedge funds
their net worth tends to be 30 or 40
million or more they're the top 10% of
the 1% and XO jet says it gives
world-class service to all its VIPs no
matter who they are
about 20 million we have 17 of them
wives
baki to improve to about point zero for
mock faster than your average commercial
one way from New York to LA will set you
back about 30 G's EXO jet owns a fleet
of 40 planes with access to about 1,000
more through its partner network o
on-demand as for competitors so the two
biggest players in the private jet space
net jets and flex jet they sell portions
of airplanes right so the client itself
takes title the airplane and then pays a
monthly management fee to access that
plan EXO jet stands in stark contrast in
the sense that we charge our clients by
the trip and in our age of the sharing
economy EXO jet has been compared to
Eber in fact the two are part owned by
the same private equity firm TPG Capital
we feel that demand of being in flowing
and stage length are the key drivers of
how much we should charge for our trip
but for high net worth jet setters cost
maybe more in afterthought morning when
you want sand flying how you want in
comfort and high-class tears EXO jet
reminds the Jet Set life is about your
journey not just your destination after
Jeff 539 one way to Pluto and clear to
land runway 6 XO Jets Irena